[Musique]
dans le centre ville de Grenade on
oublierait presque que nous sommes en
Espagne avec ses rues étroites et ses
narguilé il y a des aires de
Mdina ici tout se fait à
pied la ville a été construite sur trois
collines et celle que nous nous
apprêtons à gravir éberge l'une des
merveilles de l'humanité le monument le
plus visité d'Espagne
l'Alambra l'Alambra c'est plus qu'un
palais c'était au 13e siècle une cité
arabe fortifié avec ses jardins ses
marchés ici plus de 2000 personnes
vivaient et
[Musique]
travaillaient fraîchement restauré la
cour des Lyons doit son nom à la
fontaine qui trône au centre du
patio c'est un peu l'image la plus
blématique ici c'était la zone réservée
au sultan et à sa
famille construite vers la fin de
l'Espagne musulmane au moment où il y
avait une vraie fusion culturelle entre
musulmans et
chrétiens en face de l'Alambra se dresse
le quartier de l'albaine lui aussi de
style arabe Lola vit ici depuis 40 ans
et elle en connaît chaque
passo auparavant c'était un verger on y
plantait des légumes qu'on
mangeait
il faut se perdre dans l'albaine avant
de rejoindre le mirador
sanncolas c'est le meilleur point de vue
sur l'alembbrra surtout au moment du
coucher de
soleil pour se loger on a choisi un
autre quartier tout aussi pittoresque de
Grenade celui du sacromonté c'est le
quartier agitant de la ville depuis le
Moyen-âge et vous allez vite comprendre
sa
particularité vous pouvez vous offrir
une nuit insolite
difficile de faire plus au
calme nous sommes dans une des GRT
sac c'est un espacez petit mais très
accueillant ça vous donne une idée d'
viv les gitans les musulmans et les
Juifs quand ils ont été expulsés par les
chrétiens au 16e
siècle aujourd'hui encore ces grottes
sont utilisé à la nuit tombé
pour de flamen gitant qu'on ne trouve
qu'à
[Musique]
grenade pour notre premier bon plan nous
avons rendez-vous dans la boutique de
Daniel Daniel ne fait pas que vendre des
guitares il les fabrique
également je suis en train de faire une
guitare espagnole je'te a collé le
manche qui tiendra les
cordes un travail de haute précision qui
va durer 3 mois chaque guitare est vendu
entre 3500 et 12000
€ l'école de Grenade remonte à
1430 aujourd'hui nous sommes toujours
une trentaine de lutiers dans la région
à représenter ce mouvement cette école
autre bon plan gastronomique cette fois
la bonne surprise à Grenade c'est que
pour chaque verre commandé on vous sert
de quoi
l'accompagner voilà de la saucisse avec
une sauce à la bière et une omelette de
jambon
fromage c'est une tradition qui remonte
au 17e siècle quand un roi français est
venu en Andalousie et qu'il a demandé du
vin on a recouvert son verre d'une
tranche de jambon pour qu'aucun insecte
ne tombe dedans et à partir de ce
moment-là on a appris l'habitude de
servir chaque boisson avec des
tapasses pour terminer le séjour en
beauté on vous propose une dernière
plongée dans l'ambiance de l'Espagne
ce hamam a été construit sur les ruines
d'un ancien bain public il y en avait
plusieurs centaines à l'époque
d'andalous les bains publics étaient
formés de plusieurs salles une salle
froide une salle tiède et une salle
chaude ces bains étaient à la fois un
lieu de rencontre mais aussi d'hygiène
avant de
[Musique]
prier
sur les bords du guadal qui vire Cordou
est un musée à ciel ouvert un voyage
dans le temps chaque monument chaque
quartier à sa propre
histoire direction le centre historique
de la
ville les rues sont si étroites que les
voitures ne peuvent même pas y
accéder les ru sont étroites parce que
les immeubles ont été construits l'un à
côté de l'autre pour se protéger du
soleil pour pour
REST et après une heure de
balade en route vers notre première
incontournable la
[Musique]
Mesquita avec sa salle de prière de 200
m de long et au 850 colonnes de marbre
céit é l'une des plus grandes mosquées
du monde la meskita un monument unique
puisqu'au 13e siècle elle a été
transformée en cathédrale par les rois
catholiques c'est vraiment le monument
le plus impressionnant d'Espagne je n'ai
jamais vu une mosquée pareil sa forme et
sa combinaison avec la partie romaine et
catholique c'est
merveilleux cette cohabitation entre
monde musulman et chrétien en a fait
aujourd'hui le 5èe monument le plus
visité d'Espagne
à quelques mètres de là sur les rempars
de la ville une vue imprenable sur les
jardin de
l'Alcazar en plus d'être l'un des plus
beaux endroits de la ville ces jardins
ont aussi rendu possible l'une des plus
grandes découvertes au
monde cette sculpture représente
Christophe Colomb lorsqu'il a présenté
son projet de voyage au roi c'est donc
ici à cet endroit de l'Alcazar qu'ils
ont accepté de financer son
un rendez-vous qui au final va
bouleverser le cours de
l'Histoire Cordou est aussi connu pour
sa gastronomie et il se dit même qu'ici
on sert la meilleure tortilla du
pays la tortilla du bar Santos est
connue du monde entier elle pèse près de
kg et sa recette est un secret vieux de
ans qui est faite avec 5 kg de pommes de
terre et
30 c'est notre spécialité de la
maison passé 16h les Andalous sont bien
connus pour faire la sieste nous
décidons d'en faire autant c'est l'heure
de rejoindre notre
hôtel oui c'est une maison typique très
ancienne elle a été construite au 15e
siècle et je suis très attaché à mon
hôtel par exemple j'arrose tous les
jours les PL
Sonio comme plusieurs centaines d'autres
accord est d'ailleurs inscrit au
patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO dans les chambres lit à
baldaquin est volés en bois tout ici est
d'époque seul le Wii nous rappelle que
nous sommes bien au 21e
siècle bonjour Carlos bonjour alors
expliquez-moi comment vous travaillez le
cuir ici à
Cordou il faut d'abord humidifier la
peau avec un peu
d'eau ensuite il faut exercer une
pression sur le
cuir lui donner du relief et enfin
mettre de la pâte à pour conserver la
forme donné au
cuir ils ne sont plus qu'une dizaine de
cordonnier à encore avoir la patience de
sculpter le cuir de cette façon chaque
pièce est donc unique et nécessite entre
5 et 10 he de travail nous laissons donc
Carlos se
concentrer pour aller découvrir le le
plus ancien de la ville ambiance une
nuit
garantie là nous arrivons dans la salle
principale Cordou était la capitale de
l'Espagne musulmane il y avait plus de
600 bains dans la ville c'était le point
de rencontre et d'échange des habitants
à
l'époque il se dit même qu'une heure
passée dans ses bains équivaut à une
nuit de sommeil
complète
c'est donc en pleine forme que nous
arrivons aux écuries
[Musique]
royales chaque soir les plus grands
cavaliers de la région viennent y danser
le
flamenco vu du ciel le surnom de Séville
prend tout son sens la perle de
l'Andalousie comme l'app les Espagnols
regorge de trésors et
monuments alors aant vous prévenir tout
de suite le plus dur
ici c'est faire des
choix tous les chemins vous mner de
toute façon vers un
incontournable Paloma guide touristique
avec elle nous découvrons l'un des plus
beau lieux de sville la place d'Espagne
inauguré en 1920 la place a été
construite dans le but de montrer la
grandeur de l'Espagne mais presque un
siècle plus tard son utilité a bien
changéeron Star
Wars la
Prina rassurez-vous aujourd'hui les
seuls vaisseaux vous croiserez sont les
calèes quient la place
après cette visite nous ne résistons pas
à l'envie de prendre le large il est
possible de découvrir le lieu d'un tout
autre
angle direction ensuite notre deuxième
incontournable la cathédrale de Séville
construite autour de l'ancien minaret de
la ville vestige de l'époque
musulmane c'est la plus grande de style
gothtique au monde à l'intérieur le
spectacle est
impressionnant un mélange entre culture
moresque et
catholique son immense retable recouvert
d'or et ces sculptures vieilles du 15e
siècle en font aujourd'hui l'un des
monuments les plus visités
d'Espagne pour dormir nous avons choisi
l'hôtel le plus étonnant de la
ville il s'agit en fait d'une ville dans
la ville à l'intérieur il y a même
encore le nom des
Séville pour créer notre hôtel nous
avons acheté d'anciennes demeur qui
peuvent être relié à la maison de départ
aujourd'hui 27 maisons sont connecté
entre ell de quoi donner à
l'hôtel des air de
labyrinthe dans lequel retrouver sa
chambre relève presque de
l'impossible alors la réception a tout
prévu
poures alors nous avons un plan de l'ôel
que nous donnons à l'arrivée du client
dans ce plan sont numéroté les 27
maisons vous serez même dans une chambre
unique puisque'aucune n' la même
décoration avant que la nuit tombe il
est un endroit qu'il faut absolument
voir la cas des sévillas en français les
champignons de
Séville ici on peut voir tous les
monuments de la ville ce que je disais à
l'instant à ma famille c'est que c'est
vraiment une vue impressionnante à
360° une fois le soleil couché le lieu
change d'ambiance dans le bar situé au
sommet habitants et touristes profitent
du décor autour d'un verre offert avec
l'achat du
ticket pour le petit- dééjeuner nous
décidons de goûter à la spécialité de
Séville
la cette sorte de biscotte peut se
manger nature ou
accompagn recette date d'il y a 100 ans
c'est un peu la Madeleine de prou c'est
Vian elle a un goût d'enfance et de
nostalgie elle nous rappelle notre
grand-mère notre maison
familiale la boutique en propose des
sucréss des sal bref pour tous les goûts
nous en prenons une de
chaque impensable de quitter Séville
sans écouter un peu de flamenco pour
cela il suffit de traverser le guadal
quiire et d'arriver à tri le qutier G où
se trouent les meilleures écoles de
flamenco les gens qui passent par la rue
entendent la musique et sont curieux de
voir ce qu'il y a c'est ça le flamenco
on accueille toujours les visiteurs pour
part un spectacle
entraînant qui nécessite tout de même
des années
[Musique]
d'expérience
à la pointe de l'Andalousie Malaga
surplombe la
Méditerranée moins connu que ses
voisines grenades ou Séville la ville a
su se métamorphoser elle est devenue
aujourd'hui la destination idéale pour
les amateurs de rayon de soleil
printaniier une première balade dans le
centreville permet vite de se rendre
compte du charme de Malaga ici
l'architecture fait la part belle au
style baroque actuellement on est dans
l'alcathava l'alcathava c'est la
forteresse de l'époque musulmane elle a
été constru au 8e siècle et c'est
considéré l'endroit le mieux défendu de
l'Europe à cette époque là monument le
plus visité de la ville il permet à lui
seul de découvrir toute l'histoire
d'Andalousie cette forteresse est en
fait un mélange parfait des cultures
musulmanes et chrétiennes dans la
culture islamique il était très très
important de jouer avec les plantes
aromatiques sans ta main tu vois ils
arrivent exactement à hauteur de la
taille pour pouvoir promener ta main
dessus et t'imprégner de
l'odeur construite en forme de
labyrinthe la citadelle est remplie de
jardins et fontaines il faudrait des
heures pour tout découvrir
mais pas le temps de s'y attarder nous
devons déjà partir vers notre deuxème
incontournable qui nous attend sur son
banc un portebonheur qui aura marqué
culturellement Malaga surnommé
aujourd'hui la ville des musées le choix
est large il y en a plus de 37 nous
avons opté pour celui-ci le Centre
Pompidou version espagnol la
construction du musée a été un défi car
nous nous trouvons en dessous du niveau
de la mer nous avons donc dû faire
attention à l'humidité et à la
température
[Musique]
ambiante Miro mais Calder il y en a pour
tous les
goûts vraiment tous les goûts
oui c'est un lit avec ses coussins
l'artiste nous avait donné des consignes
il est d'ailleurs possible de s'y
allonger à défaut d'y dormir cette boî
de sardine géante nous aura ouvert
l'appétit direction le bord de mer pour
goutter à la spécialité de Malaga les
sardines grillées on aimerait que ça
fasse partie du patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO parce que c'est un plat unique
ici le poisson est frais pêché le matin
même et grillé dans la foulée là tu
piques et ensuite tu en fourche la
sardine mais ne vous fiez pas aux
apparences nous sommes loin du simple
barbecue
croyez-en notre
expérience la brûlure m en fin
prématurément à notre carrière de
cuisinier nous reprenons notre rôle de
client c'est donc rassasier que nous
nous dirigeons vers notre hôtel ici la
nuit coûte 100 € la chambre n'est pas
immense mais très confortable et surtout
à ce prix là vous pourrez profiter de la
piscine installé sur le toit et admirer
les différents monuments de
Malaga
ici on a la meilleure vue panoramique on
peut voir l'alcassamaa et la cathédrale
comme
personne l'endroit idéal pour profiter
du coucher de
soleil le lendemain matin nous filons au
marché
central construit à l'image des Halles
de Paris il permet de goûter à toutes
les spécialités espagnoles mais ce qui a
retenu notre attention c'est cette
immense vitraille réalisé par les
artisans de la
ville
maître verrier Alberto propose des cours
pour se familiariser avec son art en
l'espace d'une heure pour 20 € vous
pouvez réaliser votre propre vitrail
personnalisé encore faut-il être
minutieux et surtout très patient mais
une fois terminé le résultat s'averse
plutôt
probant avant de quitter Malaga nous
faisons un dernier petit détour loin
centreville nous sommes dans la jungle
tropicale au cœur de l'un des plus
grands jardin botanique d'Europe ici
plus de 10000 espèces venues du monde
entier ont été
planté c'est un jardin particulier
pendant un voyage de no dans toute
l'Europe un couple a pris des idées de
chacune de ces destination pour les
retranscrire dans ce
lieu aujourd'hui ce jardin est le lieu
romantique par excellence pour les
habitants jusquà fin octobre tous les
weend le jardin est loué pour des
mariages il faut prendre à temps les
lieux sont réservés plus d'un an à
[Musique]
l'avance comme aujourd'hui Cadix a
toujours su séduire les
visiteurs soleil plages et monuments
historiques les charmes de la ville
laisse peu de place aux rues qui dépasse
rarement les 2 m et demi de largeur et
où circulaire en voiture est autant vous
le dire tout de suite une très mauvaise
idée premier arrêt du weekend la tour
Tavira du haut de ces 50 m c'est le
point culminant de Cadix elle offre une
vue imprenable à
360° à
d'être un peu sportif avant d'atteindre
le somm il vous faudra gravir 173
marches la vue sur l'un des plus beaux
monuments de la ville de cadis la
cathédrale mais ce qui attire surtout
notre attention c'est ce drôle de tube
qui surplombe la tour alors ce tube est
comme le périscope d'un sous-marin il va
nous permettre de voir la ville de d'
manière totalement
inédite nous voici en fait dans une
chambre noire système grâce à un miroir
des boulies et plusieurs lentilles de se
balader dans la ville à travers cette
longue vue géante en fait on est un peu
comme Google Maps live mais de manière
plus artisanale et ici on a le le
quartier de la Vigna parce Queau 6e
siècle c'était un vignoble et ce
quartier aussi très réputé pour le
carnaval ici à
cadis Cadix est une presquîle qui
s'ouvre sur l'Atlantique au sud k de
plage our la ville bienvenue àx comme
nous disons ici la petite
Havane un surnom qui s'explique par les
similitudes entre les de villes B coloré
plage de sable fin l'illusion est à
certains endroit parfaite la preuve en
image là sur cette photo on voit
l'endroit où a ét tourné le film de
[Musique]
007ette est deeau avant derouveram
malheureusement pour nous il est déjà
l'heure de poser les valises direction
notre
hôtel pour dormir nous nous rendons chez
Maria Teresa née dans cet ancien palais
elle l'a transformé en
hôtel au début ma famille lou un
appartement au trè étage puis peu à peu
nous avons racheté tout le palais pour
en faire d'abord une résidence
d'étudiant puis un
hôtel les travaux se sont révélés plus
compliqués que
prévu ici dès qu'on fait des rénovations
on tombe sur des vestiges du 17e siècle
du 16e siècle et même du
Moyen-Âge une fois reposé il est temps
de profiter d'une spécialité qui a fait
la réputation de la ville sa vie
nocturne la cam monteka c'est un peu
l'institution acadix
c'était vraiment le lieu de réunion des
toreros des chanteurs et des danseurs de
flamenco des guitaristes tout le monde
voulait venir ici la preuve trouver une
place assise relève parfois de
l'impossible les clients sûrement
attirés par la carte et ses nombreuses
spécialité et voilà un assortiment de
nos tapasses les plus connus le plat
typique le voici du thon séché servi
comme du
jambon
le lendemain matin nous nous rendons à
20 minutes du centre-ville où se
trouvent les aras du roi d'Espagne ici
sont formés les meilleurs cavaliers
comme igncio ancien champion
olympique tu peux t'approcher n pas peur
c'est un cheval jaune il a 5 ans et on
est en train de le dresser il est très
docile e je peux tourner autour de toi
au trop comme ça et sans
problème il a vraiment un très bon
caractère car fantas et ce n'était qu'un
aperçu deux fois par semaine vous pouvez
admirer le résultat de ce savoir-faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
centenaire pour notre deuxème insolite
changement de décor et d'ambiance aussi
la côte de Cadix est connue pour être
l'un des paradis des sports nautiques
nous y retrouvons manuel professeur de
surf on est entouré par des corau ce qui
fait que le vent entre ici de manière
lente sans faire trop d'écum donc c'est
l'endroit idéal pour une première sortie
dans l'au impossible de résister à la
tentation en tenue pour un cours express
de wi et vous FZ pas au apparences si
sur le sable cela peut paraître simple
une fois dans l'eau allez bonne chance
c'est une toute autre
histoire après avoir bu la TASS
plusieurs fois le 6e essai sera enfin le
[Musique]
bon